it may not look like it but this is the
first periodic table it was conceived by
little named Frenchman called
Alexandra and mio district one toir in
1862 this was seven years before dmitri
mendeleev first periodic table which is
the ancestor of the one we all know
today the clever thing about deja
wouldn't wash system is that vertically
down the cylinder the chemical elements
fall into groupings so here we have
lithium sodium and potassium which we
know today is all part of Group 1 or the
alkali metals and a ship and doir would
have known that these share similar
chemical properties such as they're all
soft metals it can be cut easily of a
knife they also react massively of water
this is a feature common to all periodic
tables but des shook on Toit's was the
first to do it as a wizened a shock when
two are better known and why didn't he
get the credit for coming up with the
first periodic table well it's mostly
due to a publication problem the
publisher didn't actually include a
diagram of his free dimensional spiral
periodic system which as you can imagine
would be very difficult to describe in
words and it made the paper rather
obscure and difficult to understand as a
result so it's not surprising it took 30
years for his contribution to be
rediscovered
[Music]
Dasia [ __ ] wat was one of six people to
come up with a periodic table in the
1860s and the key event which paved the
way for these ideas was in 1860 when all
the world's leading chemists came
together to come up with standard virus
for all of the chemical elements this
model of his system was actually made by
the science museum in 1925 ahead of
their earliest display on the periodic
table it's probably the very first
physical realization of the shogun toire
system the science museum changed a few
details from the original system for
example here they've anglicized one of
the elements we know today is n2
nitrogen but in de chillon Toit's
original system he had his a set for a
soap which was the term introduced by
his countrymen the famous Antoine
Lavoisier another difference there only
includes the top third of shank or toire
system it stops down here at sink so the
original would have been three times the
height the original system would have
had tellurium at its halfway point and
it's for this element that disco con
toir named the whole system the telluric
screw this object and its history makes
you wonder though de chakra Noirs
contribution had been recognized at the
time perhaps he would have been a
household name like Mendeleev
you